with me now Shadow treasury Minister hi
what's Labor's position on brexit today
well for interesting that you say today
we've actually been very clear from the
summer onwards about our brexit deal but
let's just be clear about the fact that
this deal is the conservatives deal and
they've made a huge hash of it after
talking constantly about getting brexit
done they've ramped a very divisive
rhetoric with our closest training
Partners they made a huge hash of the
Northern Ireland protocol they also
signed a deal with Australia that
they're the ministers themselves are now
trying to avoid so for us the truth is
they talked about getting brexit done
but they didn't actually get anything
done and they've made a huge mass
kierstama started talking in the summer
about how we had five points that we
wanted to get done if we were in
government and that we would do things
differently with the brexit deal so the
first is we would definitely sort out
the Northern Ireland protocol the second
is we will do that well we have to have
a proper conversation they haven't even
had a proper
but it's the divisive rhetoric between
the government and the Northern Ireland
protocol but the other things like they
said they would explore trading
opportunities outside the EU Rishi sunak
after the G20 Summit in his statement
didn't say anything about a deal that
was forthcoming with the us or with
India this Mutual recognition of
professional qualifications which we've
been talking about a lot with the EU and
that would be about letting our leading
scientists and services do their work in
the EU I've mentioned that constantly in
my role to my opposite number under
Griffiths there's never been any take up
on that we've talked a lot about
security I mean we are worried about
security there's a new security pact
we've talked about from the labor party
with the EU which would be about data
sharing and making sure that we keep our
borders safe I honestly feel the
government has really let us down on
brexit they've had enormous amount of
time to do something about it and
instead it's just been about fighting
with our partners and not coming to a
grown-up agree agreement which is a
really important thing for our future
okay just explain to me again how you're
going to fix the Northern Ireland
protocol well it's about getting around
the table and speaking to people and
finding out a deal that works and we
just haven't done that I've said unless
if unless it's scrapped we're not
interested but we have they even had a
proper conversation with you I mean
people say things but if you ramp up the
device of rhetoric like they have
obviously people are not going to get
around the table but in a in our party
we want to sit down with them properly
and talk through they'll be that of
course there'll be compromises on both
sides but I haven't even seen the
government go out and have a
conversation with them and whenever it
comes up it feels like it's a closed
book and no we're on one side there or
another it's not good for the country
how does labor feel about a Swiss style
brexit well the points that we've laid
out in the summer which curious armor
and the ones that I've just gone through
are the ones that we want to follow how
do we feel about free movement of people
we won't go back to freedom of movement
that what about paying into the EU in
order to get some Services
well we've talked about making
well we wouldn't we wouldn't go back to
the things that have already been
decided so in terms of freedom of
movement in terms of
um the options that were on the table
during the second referendum that deal
has been done people voted and no we
won't be going back to that talk to me
about what's going on at the World Cup
how much um does labor support what the
England and Wales team are planning I.E
the one love armband and taking the knee
I mean personally I think we've gone
into a country where there's obviously
been a lot of controversy about this in
terms of the construction workers who
died about the human rights record of
Qatar in my opinion anything we can do
to highlight the plight of Human Rights
abuse or in terms of like I said the
construction workers anything that does
for me is a good thing is that why your
lead is not going because he doesn't
appreciate the level of Human Rights or
lack of in Qatar well you know I think
cure you know he's a massive football
fan I mean he talks about it all the
time so he's definitely yes you know I'm
sure you do know and he will be watching
it from the pub or from his house
but I mean we've decided as a party that
we didn't want to go so no one from our
party is really from the shadow
um dcms minister is not going he is not
going yes it's about where it's being
held yeah and he said he will use the
platform to shine a light
um on what Wales is doing in the first
time
well I guess he felt that this wasn't
appropriate for him to go because of the
country yeah so Mark Drakes was wrong
he's not wrong but everyone makes
different choices you're either right or
wrong well it's a broad political party
you must realize
it's a political family that he's
decided he wants to go he wants to it's
the first time that they've played and
he obviously means he wants to sh I'm
sure he will be using his platform to
shine a light on the things that we
disagree with about the country what
about David
he has gone but he's not a labor party
politician so I'm not quite sure really
I didn't notice that uh however he is um
he is someone who is supposed to be a
sports Idol he's someone who's
campaigning very hard for a Knighthood
and he's somebody that young people look
up to is he the right person to be a
representative for the Kuwaiti
government
it's his choice I mean this is David
Beckham's job but I haven't haven't yet
I haven't had I was just thinking he
doesn't have um I haven't had a
conversation with David Beckham I've
never met him but I think in my opinion
I probably wouldn't do the same thing if
I were in his shoes
but you know he's a role model
you can be a role model in some ways and
you don't have to agree with every
single thing that your role model does
he's done an amazing thing in terms of
promoting million times to represent a
country that sees openly gay people
beaten up to the extent is such outrage
the extent that a comedian has shredded
ten thousand pounds of his own
hard-earned money whatever you think of
that in order to highlight the fact that
this guy who is supposed to be a role
model for young people in the United
Kingdom is representing the Qatari
government yeah I mean I have to say in
terms of if you look at the especially
the record on lgbtq because we know how
emotional that topic is and how
difficult it is for people who are going
through the transition at the moment and
the fact that you can't express
um your own sexuality in a country and
that you're told to be quiet and behave
yourself and don't disrupt the status
quo I mean like I said I wouldn't do it
so
um what do you think about your mama and
the case that she's appealing again to
try to get a British citizenship back
that starts today she's presently still
in Syria What would the labor government
do
it's a really sad case and I was just
listening when you were presenting
saying two of the other girls are dead I
mean it's horrible because they were
only children when they were taken out
of the country and they were groomed
here you know in in my opinion if you
are groomed here and you feel like you
were a child and you were taken out we
need to take a look at that
compassionately I think we'd have to
look at all the arguments the lawyers
are making but I also feel like a 15
year old girl who got groomed here and
taken away making people stateless like
that I've taken away they chose to go
they were 15 years old I mean I'm not
I'm not defending their actions highest
Brides but I also feel like if you get
groomed in the way that they did we've
also got to look at what happens like
how did we get into a situation where
social media platforms which is how they
got groomed how did they even have
access to that at the age of 15 and get
into a position where they felt they
could leave their families travel abroad
into a world which they really probably
knew nothing about I did put that
actually to the Home Secretary there
Home Secretary Sergey Javid and he said
if we knew what he knew she would never
be allowed back in the country has he
shared that with us well he says if if
we knew what he knew he's not going to
take okay well that's obviously for
security reasons well that's a different
story I mean if we were in government
and we knew a lot more than what's just
been presented in the papers because
that's all we know really or in the
debate that we had
um in in the chamber I mean that's a
different story right I can't comment on
that until I know what the details are
maybe he does know something absolutely
explosive that would mean that she would
should be enough okay it's good to talk
to you thanks very much for joining us
really appreciate it bear with me just
one second